foreign
coming to you with more sad news today
when I woke up this morning I was
bombarded with messages that Leslie
Phillips who famously voiced the Sorting
Hat in the Harry Potter films has passed
away at the age of 98. Phillips who was
pushing a century died peacefully in his
sleep after a long battle with illness
though Phillips will be known to most of
you as the voice behind godric
gryffindor's hat Phillips had a long and
illustrious career well before the Harry
Potter films featuring in over 200
movies TV series and radio shows
collectively he was also very well known
for his role in the carry on franchise
in the late 50s his wife Zara had this
to say of her husband's passing I've
lost a wonderful husband and the public
has lost a truly great showman he was
quite simply a National Treasure people
loved him he was mobbed everywhere he
went Phillips reprized the role of the
Sorting Hat in 2001's Philosopher's
Stone 2002's chamber of secrets in
2011's Deathly Hallows where as the
talking wizard's hat he placed Hogwarts
students into one of the school's four
houses Gryffindor Slytherin Ravenclaw or
Hufflepuff and while Phillips doesn't
physically appear on screen his unique
voice is entirely synonymous with the
character you can't really have the
Sorting hands without the iconic voice
of Philips just recently we lost Robbie
Coltrane who plays rubius Hagrid and in
that video I mentioned that Coltrane was
an absolute Staple in both my childhood
and Harry Potter I think that I can
speak for everyone when I say that
Phillips had a similar impact losing
another one of the grades is certainly a
hard pill to swallow but I'm happy that
he was able to live such a long and full
life Philips like Coltrane and so many
others will be immortalized in the Harry
Potter films forever